qué país le entrega a iván duque a
gustavo petro además del manejo de la
pandemia y el estatuto de protección de
migrantes como grandes aciertos del
gobierno saliente la administración de
edu que ha sido criticada por su gestión
en materia de economía seguridad y la
lucha contra las drogas y el
narcotráfico el país se recupera tras
los impactos de la crisis sanitaria sin
embargo la tasa de pobreza ronda el 40
por ciento más de 27 millones de
personas están desempleadas cuenta con
una deuda externa que representa el 49
2% del pib del país y una inflación
interanual de dos dígitos que no se veía
desde hace dos décadas hay millones de
personas en la pobreza en colombia
después del primer pues del golpe que
significó la pandemia tiene todo bien
desempleo en dos dígitos y va a tener
que luchar contra la inflación que son
fenómenos mundiales en materia de
seguridad en el cuatrenio de edu que
fueron asesinados 957 líderes sociales y
defensores de derechos humanos
261 firmantes del acuerdo de paz con las
farc y se registraron 220 casos de
desapariciones forzadas además de la
percepción de inseguridad general que se
ubicó en un 56 por ciento según el
informe más reciente el departamento
administrativo nacional de estadística
de colombia y la permanencia de seis
conflictos armados vigentes según el
comité internacional de la cruz roja que
no han dejado al país concretar una paz
total a la que aspira a petro
lamentablemente el panorama de seguridad
es bastante preocupante con el aumento
de la presencia tanto del clan del golfo
como en las dos disidencias que en este
momento están posicionadas en algunos
lugares de colombia sobre todo del sur
de colombia del pacífico nariñense y por
supuesto la guerrilla del ln con la que
gustavo petro ya está tratando de abrir
un camino la llegada del primer líder de
izquierda en la historia del país genera
expectativas tanto por la promesa de una
retoma de las relaciones con venezuela
como por el futuro de la lucha contra
las drogas colombia sigue siendo el país
con más cultivos de coca en el mundo
en materia ambiental lo que logró
superar la meta del 30 por ciento de
áreas marinas protegidas antes del 2030
pero dejó un incremento del 15 por
ciento de la deforestación como de 174
mil hectáreas de bosque perdidas petro
llega con ambiciones de sentar las bases
para una transición energética aunque su
propuesta de frenar las exploraciones
petroleras y detener los estudios de
fracking podrían justamente frenar la
tan necesaria recuperación económica del
país